here's the thing what haven't you done
in the past year so you've gotten like
every recognition possible how are you
feeling I'm feeling so grateful
it gets me nervous because you know so
many eyes are on me and I just like I
want to be a good example you know what
I think everybody couldn't do it if I
can do it everybody can do it cuz it's I
don't I mean I don't I don't know it
when people ask what do you do I was
like I don't even know sometimes I'm in
a show sometimes I'm hosting this I'm
done sometimes I'm like creating this
and it's just been a lot it's been a lot
I mean how do you kind of give yourself
a break are you a little mentally
overwhelmed sometimes I am a little bit
I am but I'm grateful I'm very grateful
when you have that many million
Instagram followers do you get nervous
before you post do you run it by
somebody I ran it by my team but I don't
get nervous I don't I don't try I try
not to post like I mean I try not to
post like too much stuff let me pose
like one thing a day and I'm very
cautious for what I posted with my
captions how is your family feeling
about you having these moments you're
here tonight at I heart like how excited
are they for you they're really really
excited my fans are excited will might
not for my family supporters and Mike
little cousin was like I'm going to see
you I'm so excited I was just like next
time you come with me you know I mean
win I'll link you study you kind of are
taking this all in what message would
you have like to your younger self if
you could tell her one thing to my
younger self oh my god live every day
the happy as you can and enjoy what
you're doing and in the darkest times
know that something positive is gonna
happen did you have some of those dark
times now you feel like you're here I
mean I always have dark times we always
have dark times we're not perfect but I
always try to see the positive and
thanks to my my family and my team I
always have I've always turned
everything into a positive
[Music]